[Music]
[Applause]
thanks uh hey everyone thanks for coming
um thank you for coming out in terrible
terrible weather it's nice to see all
these people here yeah I'm talking about
event sourcing today uh event sourcing
is a design pattern that some of you may
or may not have heard of I use it inside
rails it doesn't fit perfectly inside of
rails so I'm going to talk about sort of
nuts and bolts uh and
tradeoffs the reason I started the
reason I started with all this was
basically over the summer I was working
with a company that did a subscription
service we sold coffee by the way raise
your hand if you work on a subscription
service right
now okay all right some of you yeah
right like this is New York has a lot of
them um recurring subscription Services
recurrence logic is actually
surprisingly complicated right you have
recurring shipments you have recurring
payments maybe you get hes which push
back the ship date maybe you get
suspensions uh we were dealing with a
lot of problems and basically the the
situation was that I had when I when I
came on board there was an existing
subscription model that had been written
uh by somebody who was didn't wasn't
given enough time and business you know
sort of business logic kind of kept on
thrashing around and so the model itself
bore a lot of scars uh so I was
routinely debugging and I was constantly
asking myself how did this record get in
its current state you always got some
customer service problem some
subscription or some record makes no
sense at all someone just spent $200 in
a pissed right and it's really hard
actually if you do it wrong it's hard to
know it's hard to know which code led to
the change right there's a bunch of
different ways of record could change
and maybe you don't have a good good
actual record of how the record changed
uh it's previous data might be
overwritten so you don't necessarily
know where you were before you got to
the wrong place you don't know where the
problem even started in the sort of
stream of changes and the relevant code
itself might not exist and this is the
worst of all but sometimes you see
something where literally the updated
that field on this record is 3 months
old and you know that you don't even
have the current code the the the code
that worked out in that time period um
and this is this this sucks basically
right it makes you end up feeling a lot
less like this K re and a lot more like
that K re so I had I had a lot of this
going on and I was very frustrated in in
a similar sense there's also this is
issue about reporting which is actually
kind of another angle on the same
problem reporting is time based and if
you've ever been asked by anyone in the
business to do reporting it's all about
well what was churn as of the year ago
uh what's the LTV all these things what
was the state of this person at some
point in the past it turns out that
rails programming and a lot of web
programming is all about let's make sure
this record is in the right place right
now right and then you always get into
this situation where you're sort of
backstepping and you're like oh I didn't
know you wanted that well you know what
it turns out they actually always wanted
they were just like too nice to ask for
it right off the start
so I was reading I've been reading about
this model uh this design PN called
event sourcing which follow wres down
it's not even that new it's from like
2005 and I wanted to give it a try
roughly speaking my interpretation of
event sourcing is that this core data is
time based immutable events which is to
say we observe that this thing happen in
time you time stamp it and you don't
really immutable meaning you probably
don't change it later after the fact
right and then you have a deterministic
item home code that calculates state
which is to say it's deterministic
meaning if you run it twice in a row it
will always return the same result and
as item potent this is super important
in a orientation land it's ipot meaning
you can run it twice in a row it won't
fire off anything you don't want to fire
off twice um and then generated entities
in this case of subcription are actually
just cashes uh they're actually just a
local calculated state that you saved um
so we were changing a lot of the
business model and I had a good
opportunity going to have to write a
bunch of new code anyway and I get an
opportunity to say hey let's like let's
make a run for the border and let's see
how this event sourcing thing works out
one of the things by the way who here
has used the gem paper trail the ruby
gem okay some of you know about this
this has a funny Echo with paper trail
but it's worth noting the differences uh
there's a similar time based laev of
changes for those of you who don't know
paper trail is a thing that you hook
into active record and every time you
like save a change to that record into
the database it persists a record of
like oh at this time something was
changed
but event sourcing defines events more
precisely usually you are asked to
upfront say I'm not just recording a
change I'm recording a creation a
cancellation a shipment uh and then
events come first not last which is say
the events are the most important piece
of data and the subscription itself is a
cach so uh let's look at some code and
show you what I'm talking about so we'll
start with creation
right let's say you work at a
subscription service that sells bottles
of shampoo in the mail this is a
terrible idea for a startup but it's not
the worst uh and let's say these are
your two models you're dealing with
you've got a subscription it uh for now
you needed to support bu bottles per
shipment that's a number user ID because
it needs to be connected to a user and
the number of bottles left right you
paid for some amount of bottles you're
going to get some left at some point in
the future uh and then you have a
subscription event right so subscription
ID it's connected to the subscription
event it belongs to a subscription event
type that's something like creation
cancellations whatever data that's the
way I was doing it it was just a
serialized Json hash and then created
that created that of course is always on
an active record but it's super
important here and you'll see
why during creation this is one way that
you could do it this is what the code
look like you do a new subscription the
creation actually there's this funny
object creational stuff that I'll come
back to later it gets actually really
complicated but then you build a
subscription event with an event type of
creation you pass data right it's a hash
bottles for shipment bottles purchased
user ID down here you pass the
subscription into a subscription
calculator object you call run you get a
result and you save it to the database
what's going going on inside the
subscription is it's pretty simple
actually during the run method it looks
for all the events attached to that
subcription it sorts them by creation
time uh and it runs them using you know
that self send Advance uncore event type
that's like the lovely Dynamic stuff you
get out of Ruby so you're kind of
setting yourself up to say whatever kind
of vent type there is I need to have a
method called Advance uncore whatever
right and you run it on the
subscription um in this case you got
Advance _ creation you're setting the
user ID you're setting the bottle for
shipment you're setting the bottles left
it is worth noting right here this is
where things start to get a little
interesting is it's not bottles
purchased that you're storing on the
subscription you're storing the bottles
left uh as we go on we'll be
incrementing and decrementing that
number based on uh events in the domain
change settings is actually pretty praic
but uh you're going to have that too
let's say somebody wants to increase or
decrease the number of bottles per
shipment they get so you have an
existing subscription in the controller
you just get it based on an ID uh and
then you create a brand new event called
change settings and then you say oh the
bottles for shipment is now updated to
this number and then you run the
calculator inside of a calculator you
add one more method Advanced change
settings and you just set the bottle for
shipment I want to be clear on one thing
here which is that every single time you
run the calculator no matter what event
you just created and what events have
already been kind of accounted in the
calculation you're running through all
of them so at this
point a user has decided to update their
subscription and the creation literally
might have been a year ago but the CIT
is going to run through all of them from
the beginning of time to now this comes
in really handy
later so you know you've got a
subscription service you're making
shipments right you're going to record
that somehow you probably wouldn't
record it as an event right it's not a
subscription event it's probably its own
Standalone thing called the shipment uh
subscription ID and let's say num
bottles a number of bottles in this box
uh and this is where start has a little
get a little tricky right because we've
written it saying saying well we
actually want to do events attach to the
subscription sort of I created that what
I decided to play with and this worked
out pretty much fine is just to expand
the definition of what is considered an
event so at the top here you just call
events 2-way and you conat the shipments
so now you have an array and it's got a
combination of different kinds of active
model active record objects right it's
got subscription events and it's got
shipments and you call sorted sort by
created at right this is the lovely
aspect of duct typing but you don't
really care what is in this array as
long as it response to created that you
can use it and then you kind of loop
through those C of events now if not
every not shipments aren't going to
respond to event type so you need to
basically say well if it's if it doesn't
respond to vent type I'm going to say
it's vent type is just its class name so
in this case you have to create a method
called Advanced
shipment and that's what this looks like
you've got the bottles left number on
the subscription and now you're
decrementing somebody bought two bottles
then you created a shipment when you
sent them two bottles they have zero
bottles
left and then recurring payment is
actually the opposite you create a
payment record which is time stamp as is
attached to a subscription and maybe you
have bottles purchased on it what you
can do then when you add that when you
take care of that in the calculator you
can basically say subscription bottles
left just add the number of bottles
purchased to increase the
balance so now some of you are thinking
that this looks like a lot of code and a
lot of hassle um and what are the
benefits of going to all this trouble so
one small thing that you get this ain't
bad right is you get a time stamp record
of changes you can sort of look through
you can get all the events and sort of
print them out in an admin screen and
say okay this person was they created a
subscription on January first 4 days
later we sent them two bottles now they
have two bottles left uh another month
later we sent them another two bottles
now they have zero bottles left and then
based on our recurring bilding logic uh
in March 1st they made another payment
for four bottles and we're back up to
four so that's nice but what really was
powerful for me is the idea of actually
getting some decoupling and saving some
debugging some debugging pain this is
your standard this is what you're doing
without events sourcing assuming you're
going straight from the controller which
is own question but uh yeah you're just
going to make changes on a subscription
and save that right to the subscriptions
table now what you've done is you've
broken this up and what the controller
does is it creates a subscription event
then calls the calculator which the
calculator give you subscription and you
save that to a database table so
decoupling hassle right but what you get
out of this and what I found to be
really powerful is that you've basically
kind of broken up the pipeline into two
different steps and on the left hand
side the data is authoritative but the
the code is simple by which I mean first
of all the subscription events are a big
deal you can't lose that table that's as
important as any other data you have in
the system but the code is actually
really simple in practice it's really
hard to get an event wrong because it
really is just like a couple of form
Fields a lot of
times on the right hand side the data is
dered in fact it's what you're actually
looking for most of the time you're
actually asking the subscription what
state are you and what's your deal right
but the code is complicated and this is
where bugs show up right so so it's nice
that the data is derived here because
it's going to give you flexibility when
you fix Bo let's give you an example
let's say you want to have an active
Boolean on the subscription record it's
pretty easy right you add a you add a
migration to create an active Boolean on
the subscription table let's say you're
going to Define active as number of
bottles remaining is greater than zero
so you add that and then you got to add
it to the calculator right let's say
when you first created active it's true
by default then when you create a
shipment when you decrement the bottles
left uh you got to check to see if the
bottle's left is zero or less you're now
inactive and if the uh payment takes you
back over bottles you know up to More
Than Zero bottles left active is
true who here sees the bub anyone see
the bug Ned if statements no no no come
on this is the bug right here and in
fact here's what's going to happen
you're going to push this out to
production you're going to you're going
to calculate the active field and
everything and someone you or someone
else is going to real wait a second
because of a recurring billing
scheduling we send them their second box
on February 5th bottles of zero but in
fact No Bottle left is zero but in fact
their bottle left will retain be stay
zero until March 1st that's not inactive
that just means we haven't built them
yet right are you actually going to say
that for a whatever like 18-day period
every two months they're going to be
inactive like what the hell is that you
know so let's say let's we want we want
to fix it this is what I'm talking about
recurrence logic sucks it's like really
hard it's very easy to get the stuff
wrong the first time so let's say
instead we make the Act definition of
active more sophisticated and we say
really what it is because everybody's a
recurring user uh the last recurring
payment was successful or there have
been no recurring payments and the only
time you can be inactive is when we
tried to rebu you and the billing failed
like that's like a suspension we got to
sent you email blah blah okay so that's
actually pretty easy again on creation
active is true right and then on payment
and only on payment let's say payment
has a success uh Bull in we can
basically say active is either true or
false based on that you know that's
all so that's awesome right you like you
push out Cod someone told you there was
a bug you fix the bug you feel good
about yourself until then you realize oh
wait a second there's like X subscribers
in the system in the production system
now and their data is right and
now you're in the really crappy
situation of having fixed de data and
just feeling like an idiot and this
always sucks this always always always
sucks you're in there on Real's console
taking half an hour to like
somebody send somebody in customer
service a hipchat message saying these
42 IDs are broken I think right you
don't even really know except for if you
did it this way because event sourcing
gives you this great
flexibility again if you did it this way
you're just right but event
souring takes events souring rescues you
from this situation you change the
calculator which fixes fixes the source
of the buck you deploy the code you test
pass all that good stuff you deploy the
code to production and then you rebuild
all the subscriptions every single one
of
them which is which sounds pretty
aggressive right all of them but here's
the thing we've already established that
the code all the bugs everything buggy
about this lives on the right side of
this line the the bug was introduced in
the calculator it wasn't because the
events were created incorrectly because
events are easy to create
right it was created in the calculator
because the interpretation of those
vents is difficult right and then the
buggy results were saved in the
subscription
table so everything on the left hand
side of that line is fine and it's only
things on the right hand side that are
broken so you fix The Code by fixing the
calculator and deploying it to
production and now you because the
calculation process is deterministic and
item potent you can basically rebuild
everything and I would do it all the
time I literally had a rate test that
was just rate re build subscriptions not
find the ones that were broken just
rebuild all of them because you know
that it's actually not worth your time
to look for the ones that were broken
now a really really big company with
very complicated customer service
remediation processes actually do does
want you to find that stuff so we didn't
have that problem yet but even so it's
really great having this like sense of
security of just saying you know what
like I don't even have to go hunting for
this it's not worth my time it turns out
that this is where a lot of the bugs
were these are these are all booleans
that I ended up adding active automatic
rebuild canel canceling which had to do
with a recurrence and if your payment
was going to uh buy you more than one
box worth of thing at a time held
spended all these things showed up this
very
briefly uh is a description of the logic
that went into every single one of these
booleans um if you can get all these
right the first time you're a much
better programmer than I
am reporting also as a nice side benefit
is really easy because now you've
basically built this very reliable sense
of calculator that can basically say you
know what and by default up until now
we've basically been running everything
up to now but it's super easy to say you
know what just run it until the last
event time if you want to know if a
subscription was held on a specific date
just tell the calculator run until that
date and then
stop this is a pretty powerful pattern
and it turns out event sourcing is
everywhere um it's in your checkbook all
Financial systems use event sourcing
every single Financial account that has
ever affected your start your life
started out at the number of zero and
then it was accumulation of transactions
over time that changed that number in
fact that is so rigorous that some of
you may or may not know this in
corporate accounting when you file your
taxes and then you realize there's a
mistake there was a mistake in the
previous T hopefully it was a mistake
and not a mistake right but if you
realize there's something you have to
correct you don't get to go back to last
year you make a new thing you recognize
a new kind of charge based on something
uh an an analysis of the
Source control is also event sourcing
you start out with an empty directory of
source code and then you add files you
change files you move them and delete
them and that's part of the reason that
git is so powerful because once you
learn everything that's inside of Git
You Can Branch you can merge you can
cherry pick you can EMA you can stash
changes you can email them around around
patches um and so again it's more
decoupling right like if you were
somebody
who actually I'm now I'm really curious
who here use subversion or another
a non like a non-distributed source
control
wow you have no idea what you avoid so
I'll tell you somebody who had used a
verion and then made the transition to
get at first the learning cve was really
intense I was like why is it all these
different things and it was just really
annoying but then you realize by giving
you all this granular control about all
these
Transformations right on these events in
your source code you have so much more
control uh over how your code works so
there's some downsides let's go over
them first of all it's definitely more
decoupling it's more code I don't think
there's anything you can do to get away
from that um so it's there's a little
more started time in terms of the code
you
read in rails we have a very funny
problem which is basically that a rails
rails is built so much of rails is built
around the single record and updating it
in place the crud operation is so wholly
in rails right even to the extent that
if you look at the a form if you know a
website uh if you know a website is a is
a rails website and you view Source on
its form you can guess what his database
scheme looks like and you'll be right
like 75% of the time right
so you got your view or maybe your
setting bottles left we've already
discussed you don't want you setting
that directly without an event right
routing has put and it wants you to do
updates controller wants to do updates
and then rails just gives you all these
really great super convenient update
attribute methods if I'm writing event
sourcing and rails there isn't a really
great way I mean I may experiment with
this but I don't know if there are
really good ways prevent somebody else
from coming in and not knowing what
they're doing not knowing the Paradigm
and they're just calling update
attribute and then like 2 weeks later
being like what's going on these updates
are not persistent
right and item pus requires a certain
amount of discipline inside this
calculator you can't do a lot of
convenient things you can't send emails
you can't initiate payments you can't
find analytics events because you
literally might you're going to run it
too much actually it's easy to set it up
though it's best to set it up so you
just don't even you never hesitate at
running this calc there you just
whenever you have any doubt about
whether or not something changed you
just run it but I think that's okay and
I think it actually works pretty well
with the world of service classes uh
which I also kind of like right so you
might have Standalone things that are
doing their own creations and also
firing those emails or initiating those
payments uh and then all calling a
calculator at the end and creation so
creation is strange let's go back to
this this was the creation slide I
showed before you call sub you call
subscription new which is to say you
don't save it in the database you
instantiate a ruby object and then you
call subscription. events. build which
is another instantiation you now have
two active record objects that are
linked together and neither of them has
been saved in database now if you are
super familiar with how active record
Association logic net works you know
that this will work because what happens
is when you call when you have these two
new things and you call Save on the
containing uh model it will save it
first and then it will like dig through
its associations and find anything that
needs to be saved and saved but by the
way I can't even tell you what happens
if that second save fails I don't
actually know it's complicated and it
feels un satisfying that it's so bound
up but like where is the creation logic
what is the subscription of
responsibility who owns this problem so
there's a there's another way you could
try to do it and I experimented with
this later which is what if you could
get a subscription ID somehow without
getting a subscription and then you
would create subscription event. create
and you would just call put the ID in it
you can do this by the way right real
isn't stop you from entering
subscription ID if it's not attached to
a subscription and then you could maybe
modify the calculator so it would also
take ID instead of just a subscription
event and then you'd save
it right but now you have to figure out
can you get an ID of a database record
that hasn't been created
yet uh and it turns out that you can
depending on the database um with
databased sequences so who
here actually who here uh does not know
what a relational database sequence is
who has not heard from okay I'll walk
you through it anyway
um most of the time when you do an
insert you don't when you don't specify
the primary key and that insert will do
two things for you it will get a unique
primary key a key that is guaranteed to
be unique for you uh and then will
insert a row with that primary key so
you kind of have uniqueness and then
somehow the driver will return the
primary key of the thing that you just
inserted it doesn't have to be done as
one if you're using
post press SQL Server Oracle I don't
know not my SQL doesn't support this SQL
light doesn't support this but if you're
using post first at least you can do
this by getting a unique primary key
first by calling select next file
subscriptions ID SE which is not super
user friendly but it works basically
that increments an internal sequence and
returns you that number no one else will
have that ID and then you can say insert
into subscriptions assuming you got four
five six back from the sequence call you
can put that manually in the insert and
it'll work just fine what's funny by the
way this is this comes in really handy
if you're like doing a data warehousing
thing and you have to prepare these
giant transactions and you want to have
an ID wrapped up with a bunch of other
inserts at the same time it's not that
commonly needed in a rails app but I
ended up wanting to use this so instead
of this we have this and this will work
just fun you have the SQL rail doesn't
really want you to do this it doesn't
support sequence calls out of the box
cuz it's not a like lowest common
denomination uh database function but
you can basic say subscription idals
cons select one SQ next 2 I right so now
you have an ID it's guaranteed to not
belong to anybody else uh and you can
you can set the calculator up to say
okay look I don't have a subscription
with this ID yet it's time for me to
create one or build one excuse me are
you Francis are you doing all of that in
case there's an an error in the
middle sorry you doing all of that in
case there's an error in the
subscription event create so you don't
have to create no I'm doing all of that
the question is if I'm doing that all
that in case there's an error in the
subscription creation it's really not
bad it's really just that it's
conceptually really weird I think to
have the creation code be so delicate
like I feel like that code which I got
to work the first
time but I feel like it was just not
very resilient it would have been really
easy to get it wrong it would have been
really easy for someone else to come
along and have a different kind of
creation and get it wrong so this is
actually much more robust you get an ID
so the first three lines are weird but
once you get an ID a lot of this I think
it's much simpler you have to wrap your
head on the concept that like this ID
might not exist yet yes is that ID
reserved another record is get sa as
you're going through the process will
they be using that that ID or jump the
question is is that ID reserved and the
answer is absolutely yes that's that's
the essential that's all the sequence
does it increments monot monotonically
um and what by the way what will happen
sometimes like in data warehousing apps
or whatever is you'll have uh processes
that get these IDs back and then they
fail for whatever reason sure fine and
then you look later in the database
actually has numerical gaps but it's
fine it turns out gaps don't matter
right um so yeah that's absolutely what
it does that's the only thing it does
really it's just like I'm the number I'm
the next number on this table or yeah
it's guaranteed unique Jesse the idea at
the bottom that subscription will either
return a new or want the exting one yes
that's right you'd have to modify the
subscription calculator that it looked
for the existing an existing
subscription based on ID or it build one
also by the way I'm not showing this but
if you call subscription. new id4 24 or
whatever that actually works when you
say it active record will put that in
the insert statement so this will
work there's another weird thing about
this which is associations with other
models some people by the way when they
write Event Source apps everything is
Event Source and it's this giant River
of crazy events which is awesome and I
don't have a ton of experience with that
though it is awesome but let's
imagine we have if if you live in a
hybrid situation which might be how you
end up starting out with this idea you
have to think to yourself which models
live outside this uh concept and Which
models kind of have you know which have
which which are Event Source and which
are sort of the more oldfashioned rails
things because rails models don't give
you a great way to know if they've been
updated really or what has been updated
let's say you've got this creation
Creations have subscriptions have uses
right and let's say we add a field to
the subscription called user hair type
which is just the hair type of the user
that we stored on the user record I
don't know if any you can see sort of
where this gets tricky you have to ask
yourself hair type when right the user
was created let's say the user was
created a year ago and let say the
subscription was initially created a
year ago right and then sometime in the
last year they came along and they
changed their hair type and now if you
run the calculator what's going to
happen it should be the exact same thing
it shouldn't update to the new hair type
so what's up that how how how are there
are there ways to solve this I tried a
couple things they both worked okay one
of those are very simply you just take
the user as it is now at the time of
Creation in the code that creates it you
grab the user and you just dump it at as
Json so that no no changes will be
changes will not be recorded with that
event you kind of freeze the state of
that user at that time another thing is
you could actually use paper trail which
is another way of doing the same thing
if you make user have a paper trail then
in the calculator you can say let me get
the user at the time that this event was
created and I'll use the hayp off
them
and changes in business logic get tricky
but I actually found that this is one of
those things where it's hard to do
either way and I think it's actually a
little easier to do uh in event sourcing
but what you have to do is you have to
be really explicit let's say you have
cancellation policies someone prepays
and they buy a bunch of shampoo and they
didn't get all the shampoo and then they
want to cancel do you refund them the
the the pro-rated portion of their unb
un shampoo you say screw it bot up front
tough left right what if you end up
changing that you can basically say you
can effectively hard code either in Ruby
code or you could actually store this in
data if you want to be simple precise
about you can basically starting on this
dat we change the policies that's all
right and in fact this ends up actually
becoming a pretty common practice like
you'll see this in accounting models all
the time where they're like oh yeah
starting with this starting now we
change how we recognize this kind of
expense um and you have a very like
clear line that you
draw so the big tradeoff really is
accuracy versus iteration speed I think
this is a lot more code uh I don't think
it would be appropriate for everything
um but you know I've worked in a lot of
e-commerce sites over the last couple of
years as I've been Consulting um and I
feel like e-commerce there are a lot of
sites where basically the revenue per
piece of data is so high that it's
probably a good idea right like if
you're building a a a dating app or a
photo sharing site and like one out a
thousand users has their photos dropped
who cares they didn't pay you any money
anyway right so it's like okay it's
probably just not worth that solving
that problem but if you're actually
literally taking $200 from a person and
then once in a while their order gets
totally messed up and customer service
is stressed out and they're calling you
and you're stressed out and you
literally don't know what happened like
no matter how smart you are the data has
been lost forever like this is this is
the time to think about something like
this um as for what's
next um I am thinking about I haven't
even really started working on this but
I'm thinking about making a gem that
works inside the rails call events r
model that boiler plat of the stuff that
would create the migrations and the
different models and the calculators and
blah blah and then give you some base
calculator logic uh if the S if you
think you might be end of this please
let me know because I have questions for
you as how you want to use it uh but
otherwise yeah I just wanted to share
this idea it was super useful to me and
it might be useful to you and uh
thanks
com yes sir so you have this example of
uh business logic changing and so if
date was past something and then you use
different policies right so do you end
up having well never get to delete code
right so you have all this logic that
stays around forever is that is that one
of the side effects yeah the question is
basically if your business logic
business policy is changing over time
and you do you end up having situations
where you basically never get to delete
code I would say yes I think uh and I
think that that's probably fine it's
ultimately not that much code if you
model it okay I would also say that like
uh you know there are there are probably
when people talk about this in very
large systems then there'll do stuff and
this is usually driven by sort of the
size of the data but they'll say stuff
like oh you know what screw it anything
older than 3 years we're just going to
Archive it snapshot it and not worry
about how it got that way right
presumably records so so maybe if that
if it gets to be just painful and just
terrible then you can just sort of
snapshot and say okay we're starting
from this but this is like this is day
zero right because presumably like
something a record that is 3 years old
even if it was a bug you're like you're
not finding it like that person already
hates you you can't get them back any
right um but yeah there there are
there's definitely a sort of a trade-off
I mean there's kind of the the dream of
oh we start from the beginning of all
time and run everything but maybe it's
just not what the Hass that's how the uh
like the r aof blog works like that like
it it stores all the operations that
happen and then periodically it will
compact all the operations into a
snapshot and then store more operations
on top of that and I think doesn't grow
unbanded and I think part of that is
like there's a Rus replication has to
take like that has to take replication
into account right isn't there like a
thing where I don't know I don't how
much because that's a big part of it too
is like transactional stuff in these
like no SQL data stores or whatever or
really any data store is like
replication is a gigantic use case for
this stuff so you can sort of see like
like when you get a bunch of different
noes of a of a of a cluster they all
kind of have to resolve to see who's
caught up to all the events and then
yeah uh Jake do you have a question uh
was going to say on this on the
sequencing thing if you have the ability
to use U IDs as your primary key uh it
makes that a lot nicer yeah that's
that's a good point right so yeah uids
are good too I played with those
too yes sir uh actually it is not a
question but more of a tesate to what
you're discussing so um I worked on
building a double entry accounting um in
a cloud platform that's called subledger
that Brian's actually wearing that shirt
right now Shameless plug um one of the
things that we learned was that um appr
in it the way you're talking about like
all people often times try to approach
data modeling from like a noun
perspective but we approach it from more
like think hopc Hopscotch so you're like
constantly additive being having
additive data um and we' realized that
if you don't have to go and update
anything in your data not only can it be
distributed very well but it Al it also
can like sit on any data store in any
Paradigm like it runs on Dynamo DB
whatever um and you learn a lot more
about your data and also how you're
doing it so I totally subscribe to that
and that and you said starting from zero
and moving forward like I've had the
least amount of problems with data
migrations warehousing by approaching it
from that manner so to kudos to that it
definitely works for sure uh let's you
got a question yes yeah um so how do you
go about like charging the customer and
making sure that like if the charge
failed or went through that that data
was reported
sure so that's yeah I didn't really show
slides of that the way I would handle
that stuff basically how do you iate
charges how do you handle like uh uh
incorrect charges and kind of VI the
business logic a lot of that stuff is
primary is like da by service classes
it's like how I like to do it uh often
fired by rake tasks if or like P jobs or
whatever um the notion really is that
you have work on the outside that's
adding events into the system but the
actual resolution of those events and
what those events the the final
implication for the subscription is not
the service classes throughout so we'd
have a reer and the Rebuilder would
basically say Okay based on we would
also set like rebuild dates or things
like that's on the subscription and you
can build all these fields if they're
just convenient to have there you know
and we say based on your rebuild day oh
we're X number of days from whatever
we're going to rebuild it and we're
going to make an attempt and have our
branch and logic if it's successful we
create a successful payment if it's a
failure then we kind of like uh record a
failed payment and send you an email and
of course then you have like usually
like your your sort of like steps of
like first you try day one you send them
meils then you try on day two then you
try on day four or whatever and then a
certain point you say okay whatever then
I'm coming back um those happen outside
the calculator anyway and this doesn't
make that any easier or Harder by itself
like dealing logic is still just like a
lot of work really and Rec like that
part of recurrence logic but at the end
of the day what you can do what what
what does help you is the notion that
the the subscription can add these
fields that sort of help you figure out
when to build next and that stuff which
a lot of that is like the core of why uh
recurrence is difficult
um that you can really iterate on and
kind of change and keep redefining
knowing that any bugs that you get you
can just sort of fix them Al
away
question how do you handle the side
effects like sending emails the side all
the side the questions of how you handle
side effects they're all Happ in
responses can't do them in calculators
that's that's basically the it right
like it could be done there it could be
done be done in a controller if you want
to go old school you know but generally
like the C you have to be able to safely
call it all the time for any reason at
all it's it's not that different from
like I mean it's any kind of it's It's a
cash update really right it's similar to
like a redraw an EMP or something you
should just be able to do it whatever
the hell you feel like it right and not
and have like no concern about having a
that's any questions yeah have you had
any trouble with scha changes I've run
into some problems where you something
simp you want to rename an attribute in
a
table in the in the in the in this
example would that be in the event or in
the subscription sub okay so the
question is have I had any problems with
scheme changes and actually I would say
no the reason being that I mean scheme
changes I guess are always work but um
it's a lot easier because you can always
sort of rebuild when you've deploy now
of course like if
you're so what's what's the easy example
is renaming a column which you're not
even going to ask for CU that's like so
obvious it's not not that interesting
the hard example is like let's say you
had a a Boolean field and concept
doesn't even make sense right it took
you a while to figure this out and
you're actually going to delete that
field and replace it with two other
fields and then you got to build the
subscription job that is kind of a
migration problem right because if you
delete that column it's code living on
it maybe the the rebuild job takes like
5 minutes is that scheduled down time
blah blah blah it's it's not that
different from other kind of migration
problems you could do it in stages you
add the Duna columns do the rebuild and
then you know have like the second phase
kind of deployed um so it doesn't save
you from that but what it does help you
do is basically keep redefining things
like I never got into a situation with
this model where there was a Boolean on
on the subscription and I was like God I
just hate what this is called or I hate
the way we defined it but I can't fix it
because I don't know what I'll lose
right because there's nothing in there
that is important actually it's all
coming out of the calculator so you're
very free to be like it I'm lead
toying this whole thing this concept
sucks I'm deleting this field I'm
creating three new ones I'm putting in
the calculator I'm just going to run it
I'm going to populate it and that'll be
awesome other questions do you generally
think of the stuff pick you back on that
you don't think of the stuff inside the
events as private to the
calculator good question is do you do
you generally think of the stuff inside
the events as private to the calculator
and I would say generally yes yeah the
events are uh uh yeah they're very low
level they're not very readable they're
not super they will change over time
once in a while you'll end up redefining
it oh you got to add to add this new
field the calculator by the way does
have to check like oh this thing wasn't
here from the start but once it starts
showing up I'm going to treat it this
way yeah and so it's very like it's got
a bit of mess in there um but yeah you
would it would be really rare that you
expose that directly to like end users
in any way you do want it to sort of uh
be kind of contained in the sub the
current this by the way is projection
right like the subscription is a
projection it's some sort of like Chic
form you can even imagine pulling this
into to like an elastic search cluster
if you wanted to do some other stuff for
that uh other question one last
question okay oh yeah in addition to
kind of rebuilding the entire cash um
would you ever consider just like
recalculating everything and checking
against every record in the cach and
then being like wow some of these don't
match I must have a bug well the thing
the thing is that would be a super rare
so the question is do you ever consider
rebuilding everything not saving it
comparing to what's already in the
database table and seeing if there
discrepancies and saying I must have a
bug I guess if your code was super
complicated you might have to worry
about possib like that implies that a
calculator isn't actually deterministic
that it had a different result running
at a different time um assuming there's
no new events since right that which is
always kind of question um but for the
most part it's just not it's if you do
it right or my experence it wasn't that
interesting the problem you know um
again I think maybe the more common use
case would be if you were at a much a
very big company that had very like
explicit like fixed strategies where you
had to actually find who was affected by
a bug so customer service could
proactively reach out to them then you
would probably that's how you do it okay
thanks we U we actually do gold Master
testing at code climate to check that
our analysis algorithms don't change
unexpectedly given a commit in our
analysis like if we make a change to the
analysis it's not supposed to change in
the Anis result it actually is pretty
hard to do that because it's super
complicated so we will save a snapshot
of the answer persisted on disk and then
we'll rerun the new algorithm and can
just compare every single field to make
sure that it doesn't shift unexpectedly
it's not a event sourcing but because
we're in one of those cases where we
need to make sure it's deterministic and
like if it's not deterministic
everything explodes though it is one
Geto analyzing another G repo right so
it's it's pretty it is kind of a EV
sourcing or you could say yeah right
yeah is true I didn't think
about thanks Francis
you